250 millions d'euros c'est le montant de
l'aide internationale qui sera apportée
en urgence à la capitale libanaise
alors que les dégâts matériels se
chiffre à plus de 15 milliards de
dollars montant que le liban lourdement
endettés ne peut financer seule
le président du pays s'est adressé
directement aux donateurs durant la
conférence de soutien est bon construire
ce qui a été détruit et redonner de
l'éclat à beyrouth qui demande beaucoup
les besoins sont très importants et ne
devons accélérer pour répondre surtout
avant l'arrivée de l'hiver car la
souffrance des citoyens sans abri va
s'accroître à la lumière de toutes ces
situations stressantes
parmi les engagements annoncés l'union
européenne souhaite contribuer pour 60
millions d'euros au programme les états
du golfe ont également ouvert leur
portefeuille comme le qatar j'en fais
normalement nous allons annoncer dans
les prochains jours notre participation
à la reconstruction de beyrouth à
travers les programmes qui seront
retenues contre temps nous nous sommes
dépêchés de répondre à l'appel de nos
frères du liban et à leur fournir une
aide d'urgence immédiate évalué à 50
millions de dollars
côté américain sans fournir de chiffres
donald trump a annoncé que son pays
était désireux de fournir une aide au
peuple libanais
ce qui est de l'humanitaire nous nous
devons de le faire on doit le faire
c'est on peut se demander comment un
pays peut survivre à une telle tragédie
c'est un tel niveau que des gens là bas
me disent qu'ils n'ont jamais rien vu de
tel auparavant ils n'ont jamais rien vu
de semblable à cette explosion
nous allons donc les aider et de façon
importante le royaume-uni a lui annoncé
une aide de près de 22 millions d'euros
l'espagne la norvège le danemark ont
aussi confirmé leur contribution
financière
l'aide sera coordonnée par les nations
unies et fournit directement à la
population libanaise ses 250 millions
seront répartis sur quatre axes
prioritaires la santé l'alimentation la
réhabilitation des écoles ainsi que la
reconstruction des logements ravagé soit
un vaste chantier en perspective